[Music]
you're watching Mike here's a little
taste of what we've got for you in the
next 10 minutes
controlling characters with your mind is
this the future of gaming then next
generation virtual reality I try out new
head tracking technology and we're
heading back at a Bolivian drug cartel
in our games review welcome to swipe
this week we've come to visit a brand
new tech innovation hub the Taylor
Center has been set up by the Royal
Academy of Engineering to help turn
thousands of British ideas into global
successes so we decided to come and have
a look at a few of those ideas and meet
the entrepreneurs behind them ok so I'm
just going to put on the cap here now
you ever heard of neuro gaming it's
where you play video games using your
brainwaves rather than a controller the
technology is aimed at people with
physical disabilities to control this
character you imagine laughs tower
movement to move to the left and right
our movement to move them to the right
so I just need to sort of imagine the
imagery to get it to kind of yeah so
it's imagining left in the width perhaps
with your right arm or left in the whip
with your left
so could games like this become more
mainstream in the future gamers like a
challenge you know gamers that are
professional gaming they're learning a
motor skill to control a normal
controller so therefore they're likely
to have a an interest in gain control of
their brain activity you can probably
tell from my performance it's not the
easiest thing to master I feel like I
don't quite have the sort of level of
control over my character that I might
expect if I was say playing on a
traditional console I'm sitting here I'm
talking you're trying to listen to me
you know you're using your mouth and
you're you know there's all types of
interferences going on there that's one
and impact on the performance you really
have to get until there's a one it's
still a relatively new area but neural
gaming is growing the world's first side
battle on took place late last year the
event saw people with physical
disabilities compete with the aid of
assistive technology including a brain
computer interface race and the
organizers think there's potential to
take things a step further at the moment
these neural games in brain ridden
phasers allowed trust a limited number
of commands this performance can be
improved in the future by implanting the
devices but then of course we have the
problem of safety and ethical issues
head implants probably aren't going to
replace consoles just yet but the
potential behind neuro gaming technology
is clear so there's every chance it
could be making waves in the years to
come
Chris Creegan Sky News stay with us if
you like a VR they tell me they've got a
unique kind of head tracking technology
here that can help make the experience
even more real I'll be getting a go on
that right after a roundup of this
week's tech news here's a wristband with
the potential to help your social life
with a warning but if your conversation
starts getting boring scientists from
MIT loaded it with sensors capturing
data like heart rate and movement so it
can read the tone of a conversation it's
claimed artificially intelligent chat
box could replace 250,000 public sector
jobs in the next 15 years Policy
Institute reform says even jobs
primarily based on human interaction are
at risk from computer-based advances
Safer Internet day gave us a reality
check this week a report which was part
of the campaign showed more than 20% of
children aged 8 to 17 have been bullied
with images or videos online and Twitter
announced new measures to try and
protect its users from abuse on the site
they include preventing banned users
from creating new accounts plus a
feature that removes tweets with
potentially
give content stick around for our games
review with fighting Klingons in the
trench with the new Star Trek bridge
crew but before that well I've got a lot
of kits on I feel like I'm about to go
scuba diving but actually we're going to
talk about this little bit here this
technology that you've been working on
Michael called the star tracker right
why is equal to star tracker because we
stick little stars on to the ceiling
these are retro reflective stickers and
then this camera is actually seeing them
and working out the position of the
headset just by the constellation of
these stickers or stars so where are you
going to take me to demonstrate how
these stars work what about a rooftop oh
okay
oh yeah I'm on top with your building
it's over the building look you've
managed to make some solar panels out of
these array where we are there some
cables they were folded up and we put
some solar panels instead so talk to me
about how these stars are working with
this bit right now so the stars are put
onto the ceiling and on your headset is
a little camera that is looking up and
light is reflecting from them and is
working out the position of your headset
and so if you move now you will see that
your head is moving and the virtual
world is also moving you can actually
walk in the virtual world I feel a bit
sick and I'm a little bit worried about
falling off this roof as well well my
goodness I can see I'm looking down at
the road so why is this better than the
current VR devices out there because
other companies they must be working on
this kind of technology to current VR
technology is developed for a single
user and primarily for gaming and the
next generation of VR technology is for
multi-user many users an unlimited space
I'm just faced so could I walk up and
down the staircases of a 16-story
building with this absolutely and it
would it would keep up with me
it will keep up with you know latency
the virtual environment can be addressed
to be matching but I have to wear this
because this is pretty heavy as it's the
battery that is a very high power
word gaming computer this is only there
to give you a better experience better
resolution how far do you think we are
from the totally immersive VR experience
incorporating all five senses that is a
really difficult question because the
question is as well how far do you need
to go and how far I think there are lots
of companies working on slivers of
innovation go on for 5-10 years 2025
really been so far we are already
working now with companies we're moving
around is a requirement last week we
were cycling actually with our
technology I can take this off because I
feel a little bit sick well look thanks
thanks for showing me around on the
rooftop right we're going to break away
from the innovation hub just for a
couple of minutes now because it's time
for this week's games review here's Ross
with a few soon-to-be-released titles
Ghost Recon wildlands sits under the Tom
Clancy umbrella and it is now coming out
I have waited so long for this game and
you know what it's going to be
unbelievable because it's the first
open-world Ghost Recon that will give
you so much opportunity to explore the
vast south america bolivian land it is
all around santa blanco drunk cartel who
are basically taking over the country
instead of setting up a massive war the
american government have decided to send
in the ghosts yes a Special Forces team
of four people and that can be yourself
playing as a single player with three AI
or you could then play with three
friends and this is one of the first
ever open world games where four of you
can play the whole story through
leggo has become pretty dynamic within
the videogames world now I suppose you
could compare this to the likes of your
minecraft game and it's all around
becoming a master builder within the
world of Lego you can create anything in
the Lego types with all the bricks that
you've got they've got actual kind of
like buildings and pieces of Lego that
have been built already that you can
place into your world or you can just
basically do whatever you want with
storylines that are set in the walls
that you go into you can go and help a
king find a sword or you can help a
caveman build a cave and another great
thing they've added into this is the
online functionality so you can go into
other people's worlds and join in their
adventures or people can come into yours
and join you and yours if it's anywhere
near what minecraft offers as a game
lego world could definitely take Lego to
another level within the video console
gaming industry come to Lego worlds in
VR you've experienced many things
already and there is another great
experience within the star trek world
with Star Trek bridge crew you can play
as either the captain the helm the
tactician or the engineer and the
amazing thing here is it's going to be
one of the first games that I'm going to
hopefully experience where you can play
with other people online so three of
your friends can join you and you can
take control of this brand-new starship
and venture in to what is known as the
trench you're off to this vast area of
space where you're hopefully going to
try and find a new area for the Vulcan
race to populate and I cannot wait to
just imagine and put that VR headset on
and put myself on the bridge of my very
own starship and hopefully with three of
my friends taken control obviously try
and take the captain's role and see what
I can do and to make sure we can get
through all of the missions but I cannot
wait for this experience there have been
so many great ones so far but this could
definitely take VR to another level
while out it for this week's episode
why not follow us on Twitter at Sky News
Skype and you can see what we get up to
throughout the week
I'll be back next time hope you can join
us then bye bye
[Music]